I have long been  skeptical of this phrase politics is  Downstream of culture not because it  isn't true in the sense that we need to  make movies but because I think it lets  Republican politicians off the hook I  think it is a kind of libertarian cope  to say the government is always bad the  government can never do anything right  so we just need people outside of the  government to do everything for us it's  a way to say okay we're going to  surrender the entire political order but  we live in a republic we live in  self-government so in self-government in  all states but especially in  self-government  the distinction between the culture and  the politics is pretty blurry because  it's we the people are supposed to be  doing both of those things